i didn't realize how hard it was going
to be to talk and do this at the same
time so we're kind of talking about
periods right now people asked
us
what makes a woman what makes someone
feminine
is it the way you physically present
yourself how long your hair is
how painted your nails are how much
makeup you wear
is the way you behave the way you speak
the way you cross your legs stand walk
hold your wrist
this question is on a lot of people's
minds so we decided to make an episode
about these questions
we brought together six girls and one
guy with cameras and mics off
can they find the odd man out
i've got some pretty juicy questions
birth control is a big one
makeup is another big one i should write
that down makeup
you know talk about the obvious you know
periods i don't know i'm just gonna
try my best and pray my strategy is
going to be focused on looking for small
details on how people text
so if people use a lot of exclamation
marks and stuff or maybe if someone's
trying to be too
overly friendly you know what i mean
looking for the person who kind of waits
for everyone else to answer
i think that is going to be the ticket
i plan on two main strategies one the
types of
strategies actually i'm a little bit
more masculine like i
act a little bit more like a guy i think
i don't know that many things about
like makeup and fashion and the
stereotypical girl things
i'm really trying to get into like the
head of the mall and see you know what
would i do if i was the mole
i am the secret mole
my name is chris but i'm crystal i was
raised by a single mom
my family is full of girls i'm trying to
go in here you know and lead
lead with my best foot forward you know
like just be the person that i am
and hopefully you know uh break down
some preconceived notions
about what guys are let's do it
take the chat away everyone go time
starts now
okay i'm gonna ask the first question um
does anyone
wear makeup if so
name a specific product
she wants to know where we're from from
indiana
uh so name specific product i don't know
if anyone saw that question
okay i wear
a sephora also my eggs
sticky so sorry okay
this is cute guys this is really
stressful like i don't know why this is
so stressful
36b oh my god people are asking about
makeup i love makeup but this is just
talking about brow size i think i'm like
a thirty fourth i'm done
everyone's trying to crosstalk 34c 32b
[Laughter]
okay nail shapes um
coffin hands down
nobody knows too much about sure they'll
say for sure
okay uh they're talking about nails
right now and i don't actually know how
to do my nails
interesting okay wow we're really going
up already the ladies are talking about
bra sizes they're probably where we're
from
they're only square nails from lead
outer nails for the win i can't even
tell who's who there's so many people
favorite form of self-care
oh favorite form of self-care
well do you ever want to try to do
anything for
k von d locket foundation oh i love that
from here
i'm smelling rock snails poor strips why
am i shaking
okay okay because they hurt okay i love
the sheet masks honestly yes they're
because they hurt you too blah blah blah
i like face masks
masks they're bomb okay yeah yeah yeah
um what's it called self-care right now
i and i just don't know what to say like
obviously i asked the question so yeah
already i'm looking at aya
one minute left oh gosh there's one
minute left okay
i didn't realize we had last night oh my
gosh this is getting insane
i wear of makeup
i don't wear a lot of makeup i just wear
like um
eyeliner makeup now this is so cool
i wish i could type
oh my god this is a nightmare
just mascara
all right what about the favorite makeup
brand
this is actually really hard i don't
know who did you yeah someone's actually
saying that they're all natural and i'm
like the same but like
i gotta not seem that way when i'm doing
this what's my favorite makeup brand
it's gonna say let's make a brand um
and here you go
you raise my girl you know i gotta put
something cool
[Music]
and that is time this round was a little
crazy
i mean i don't know it was all moving so
fast i don't have my glasses on so it
was a lot to catch up on
we went from bra sizes to makeup to
self-care i couldn't even read
what everyone said because i was so
stressed about what i was saying
i mean colourpop is used for your eyes
right you can use it like here that's
what my roommate did
i think honestly it fired off so quick
so very quick
but i think i kept up pretty well
and a private message send me your vote
for who you think the mole is
okay so i don't think logan is the mole
and i don't think anna's the mole at
first i did because she's the only one
who doesn't have a last name in this
chat
i'm definitely getting voted because i
don't have a last name actually i might
vote for crystal because i'm looking
through the chat
and like crystal was the one who was
like i don't wear a lot of makeup i'm a
natural girl which is fine but she's
probably spoke around like
three times throughout the whole thing
nirvana
maybe crystal might be on my sas
list i think i'm voting for the article
logan you have my vote only because you
said you only wear mascara and i feel
like
most girls have like mascara and maybe
lip gloss or like mascara
maybe a little bit of tinted moisturizer
i don't know
crystal i think she's she's fine i don't
think she's suspicious
i've never met a logan a girl named
logan i'm voting for logan
[Music]
i'll go with logan because her name
sounds like a guy so maybe other people
who don't know will go with that you
know
bring it away from me i'm voting for
crystal
on this round i'm so nervous
i'm gonna vote for anna i feel like i've
really got to be on my game
because girls really know knowing what's
going on
the person eliminated this round is
logan sorry logan
because my name is logan that's a man's
name
i felt like i was on my game but i still
think it's
crystal time starts now
whoa whoa whoa okay down to it why is
your least favorite part of being a
woman what do you feel is a huge
expectation of that's a hard question
no that's uh i'm so worried about coming
off as masculine
tampons i can't do
[Music]
it do you check the bag in the car dude
okay i saw this tweet and it was
real talk do you get a check to see
would get in that car are you a man and
it was like yeah
always check before where are you
this sucks it's a little god damn it
gross for me i pepper spray on my
keychain
i have four pepper sprays oh my god
dang one for each bag
i do actually have paper sprays but i
don't have that bag i just kind of keep
them in different places so i keep on at
work
i didn't realize how hard it was going
to be to talk and do this at the same
time so we're kind of talking about
periods right now people
asked uh
i facetime my bestie which is true
we were like 12 no we were really
freshmen and we were both so awkward
and yeah i mean catcalling is something
that happens all the time even married
men
it's happened when they're walking i'm
not figuring anything out about people i
don't know
what to think now we're talking about
gel versus acrylic
nails um i'm trying to say things that
validates myself as a woman but
i also don't want to say anything that's
like too cliche this is really hard
we also talked about like one of my
favorite things about being an adult is
being able to afford gel lmao
um we kind of talked about like
privileged
people and like how being a girl you
deal with a lot of sexism
and just like being scared caring like
oh my god
all right and that is time i think i
want to vote
anna out and i don't feel she was typing
that much
i'm gonna go with nirvana just just
because i'm sorry girl i'm sorry
yeah i'm gonna do crystal because
crystal said something about keeping her
nails short but then she started talking
about like how she gets her nails done
so that's what i'm gonna go for
i think i'm gonna vote messiah
i am gonna suspect aya just because
like she says crash landing on you i'm
sorry i feel bad saying this but like
these are just things that i've never
heard girls say
i'm gonna go with her also because i
just believe in crystal now and
i'm on her side and lyrical seems like a
girl too and so does nirvana
i wonder who the guy is i think i'm just
gonna keep hammering anna
to be honest anna if you watch this and
they show this part in the episode
i don't hate you i'm so sorry you just
don't have a last name
the person eliminated this round
is anna
[Music]
somebody doesn't care somebody's trying
to get to that money
ah that sucks it makes sense i think
they were all typing the same way i hope
they win
they're better i think it might be
crystal
three round three we made it
mama we made it time starts now okay so
i asked what's your morning routine when
you're not in quarantine because i feel
like that'll tell
what is your morning routine when not in
quarantine
okay wake up check my phone
oily skin i shower at
night take a shower
i'm a morning shower for sure my face
brush my teeth
get cute lol
this is so cool um we're talking about
like what we want to do and like all
these people are
so smart i love it like he's nervous too
oh my god let's be friends please oh my
god
everyone does research and two people
are trying to be doctors and i just
okay the reason i ask anybody cheers to
dance because i'm on a cheer team i'm a
co-captain of my cheer team
and i feel like if anybody were to claim
that they were they would know
all the terminology right right i hope
so
i play viola i'd probably follow myself
oh dance oh everybody's a dancer that's
so cute
co-captain of my cheer team okay so
y'all remember i think i said if someone
mentions cheer i'm gonna
kind of be a little suspicious what's
underwear learn to turn my legs but hair
type
squats favorite clothing store when you
were younger okay
i live by squats i used to
love randy and urban
but because of everything
no store at all i'll hand me down
support
eating my diet
i live by eating and
[Music]
i think i is the best of us i think i is
the best of us
we're talking about like where we like
to shop i guess oh my gosh
um okay we're talking about boba i love
boba
uh eat everything for some seafood i get
and delivery i love me some crab
i love crab
i need some food i didn't i don't know
when we got into the food conversation
honestly
but we're here
me too nirvana
i hate seafood all seafood
oh
that crap you know we're all talking
about things that i do like we're
talking about skincare routine
and what i shared was actually my
skincare routine i have bunches of face
masks the only thing the only person who
isn't like
more typically feminine i think out of
everybody
um in the in the slightest bit is um
maybe
aya i honestly think we got them all out
i really do
i think maybe i'm gonna vote lyrical and
it's not because i don't think she's a
girl i honestly think all of us are girl
at this point
part of me is telling me to go with
crystal just because she said something
about the jj's
and i don't know i just don't think i
would just come out saying the word for
jj's i don't know
i don't think it's crystal if it's
crystal
i'm gonna be very disappointed
honestly i might go with aya again i'm
sorry girl
like i feel so bad it's difficult to
keep up with the chats because i'm
trying to type
and i know that they're all trying to
type and we're all kind of like oh but i
think i'm gonna go
with lyrical because sometimes like the
way that they type kind of changes up a
little bit i don't know if that's
because it's a typo if it's just me
mixing up the names so actually
um we have a tie of course so
uh we are gonna do a vote between two
people
lyrical and ayah
okay aya it can't be me no
come on my favorite color is literally
pink even though that's stereotypical i
don't know
i never suspected lyrical maybe i should
i'm just going to go with ayah because
that's who i first said i'm sorry
girl like i feel really bad i'm going to
bet it was aya i'm going to vote lyrical
the person eliminated this round is ayah
okay i think i'm good girl i'm out
it's a little bit of a relief honestly i
was way too stressed out
when i was playing the game but when i
told my parents that i was going to be
filming that day
my mom went so wait are you pretending
to be a boy and i said no no
i am the girl and my mom went oh so you
have to actually be a girl that's going
to be hard for you and i was like yeah
it will
if you don't think the mole is in the
game and you would like to end the game
give me a thumbs up
nirvana i don't know oh [ __ ] it's only
one person voted
all right so we are gonna proceed okay
nirvana thinks the mole is out round
three minutes starts yeah i'm gonna ask
about zodiac signs i feel like girls
follow zodiac signs more than
guys items so yeah that's what i'm going
to ask us
everyone else like i know i believe in
them
let's see do you guys believe in zodiac
signs
i'm a person you know like there's like
confusion about like whether you're you
could be a christian and believe that
libras
are and i still don't really know what's
the best
no joke they're literally the best oh my
god i'm sorry
yeah leaders are the best no joke thank
you
ellie i want to say it like that
capricorns
beers jan 16
2002. i'm september
24th skincare
i use curology
so mean crystals so we are talking about
sodium
for acne scars
scrub it's in a blue
it's in a light blue container
smells like mint it makes
my face tingle
crystal brought up this formula thing
that no one has heard of
that's a little
what's sausage oh no time's up no way
your time is up it's not going nothing
so far and
that is time what caused the chat
crystal you haven't convinced me yet
girl
you haven't convinced me yet i kind of
trust nirvana i feel like she's a girl
but it's between crystal and lyrical
right now i think i'm gonna go for
crystal just because she mentioned like
products that we didn't really know
about i don't know i think about
lyrical because she was getting most
votes last game so
maybe my vote is for
lyrical i think this is the final one i
think i think i did it
whoa come on so
there has been another tie so the tie
was between
lyrical and crystal
interesting oh i might be found out you
guys have to pick crystal
something isn't right about her i'm not
gonna vote my girl crystal
because she is
my capricorn twin so i'm not voting my
capricorn girl
out i mean i put crystal before
so i'm gonna go with crystal again all
right y'all we are dead locked
which means that is a tie
so i haven't been in this position
before oh my god
okay so this is a good idea so i asked
him to let them say something so
again that you can say to the whole
group
only through chat to convince them to
keep you
this must be stressful for them i feel
so bad
but if one of them is the mole i don't
feel bad ah
what's something good um
y'all better not blow me off oh my gosh
okay now my heart's being fast again so
i'm saying crystal just because i don't
know
where that phrase is from i'm sorry i'm
not up to
date on social media i don't want to
vote crystal out but should i do it for
the team
i don't know
[Music]
the person eliminated this round
is crystal
okay i didn't i didn't make it to the
end
son of a gun man i wonder what it was i
can't wait to hear from them i can't
wait to hear what they see and what they
say
here we go so if the lights behind
me turn red that means you lost the game
and the mole is still
in this chest if the lights turn green
it means you won
and you already got rid of the mold
he's messing us
[Music]
thank the lord i really want to know who
it is now oh my god
all right yes
i knew it i knew i should do it oh my
god
i'm not even able to process what just
happened we've won
i did what i had to do okay look toe
touch
pipe perky my three jumps all right
let's go i got the money hit me up
i got the bread now honestly
i think it was the quote that crystal
gave at the end
i'm honestly so proud of us like i'm not
shocked because we have three people
left in the game like the more should
have been out at that point
and like i really wonder if it's crystal
now because if it was her that was a
very good decision to get her out in the
last round i'm so sorry baby
also this game was really fun to play
yeah i loved it
enjoyed every second of it everyone
please reveal yourselves
in three two one
[Music]
hi hi
wait i don't know oh my god who what's
crystal
what at the beginning
no oh my god honestly
where am i the last round guys i'm so
glad we went through with the last round
i know wait so you guys win
did you guys vote crystal out hey
just because my name's logan doesn't
mean i'm a
my goodness man knew it i don't know you
said something like vajayjay or
something like that i was like
talking about the jj i said no that's
the guy
if we're not fair enough promise i'm not
a liar i really really
hate deception i'm like i'm a truthful
straight up
say it like it is kind of person so
every round i was like
crystal is that your real name my real
name is chris
[Music]
that's a good one honestly all i can say
is i suspected
chris or crystal from the beginning i
knew it
i honestly thought it was so insane how
we found them at the last second
i feel like what makes a woman a woman
is not so much about
you know the traditional things like
physical traits and whatnot or body
parts but more so
about our experiences you know what
we've been through what have you seen
as a woman what have you felt whether
you're woman
man non-binary whatever it is like that
journey is 100 yours to go through
if you inside feel like you are actually
a woman then
that's there it is you're the only one
who can tell anyone else who you are
because you don't want to know yourself
the best